in the pandemic year of 2020
executions carried out worldwide
decreased significantly
that's according to a new report amnesty
international says more and more
nations are restricting the use of the
death penalty but it points to worrisome
increases
in some countries in its annual report
amnesty says
china continues to execute or sentenced
to death thousands of people each year
and
has criticized beijing for keeping the
exact number secret
amnesty said iran ranked second with at
least 246 executions last year
followed by egypt which recorded a
three-fold increase
from the previous year and in the united
states the
only country in the americas that still
applies to the death penalty the
federal government resumed executions in
the final months of the trump
presidency
well for more now i'm joined now by
chiara san giorgio
international's advisor on the death
penalty and co-author of the report
in london thank you for being with us
what's behind
the decrease of executions worldwide has
the pandemic played a big role in
uh that you for having me today uh yes
as you say
um we recorded um the lowest number of
executions in at least a decade and
there are let's say three main factors
um the contributed result on one hand
we saw two of the countries that are
have been
in recent years responsible for a high
number of executions
significantly drop their national tally
these were iraq
which held its executions and saudi
arabia
which reported a reduction of 86 percent
um also we saw that the covet 19
restrictions also led to some executions
being put on hold
that was the case for example in many in
several u.s
states and at the opposite hand we also
saw that
some countries and some authorities like
in the case of the u.s federal
authorities
displayed a disturbing determination to
pursue
executions and the sentences at the time
when motherboard was focused on civil
life
now your organization is campaigning for
the abolition abolition of the
death penalty do you think it's
realistic to expect that all countries
will abandon it is there a consensus
emerging on this issue
we believe so and the figures are on our
side
when amnesty international began
campaigning for abolition in 1977
we had 16 countries that aboriginal
penalty and this figure is now 108
and now we count only 20 countries last
year we're actually 18
that carry out executions every year i
think it's particularly significant for
this year and the fact that iraq and
saudi arabia as i mentioned
were among the sort of good news the
ones that the countries are mostly
contributed to
the decrease in the recorded executions
and we hope that china which still
shows its use of the penalty in secrecy
we follow suit
your son giorgio thank you very much for
being with us that was ciara sangiojo
amnesty international's advisor on the
death penalty and co-author
of the report in london
thank you so much